Taking a little breather here just
to remind you what we're doing.
So we have this, for
basically, we're doing window-based
object detection, right?
The training, we basically get it,
see it says obtain training data.
Doesn't say how.
You just hopefully can go to the web,
or like I said,
you pay somebody to click on things,
because you can do that these days.
You define some features, so
you have to figure out what it is
you're going to measure about it.
And then you're going to
train a classifier, and
that's what's shown here.
So I take my windows that can, and
I I, I have positives and negatives,
that comes from this great big set of
training examples you see over here on
the left, I've got these cars, then over
on the right, you've got these non-cars.
So it is, you use those training
examples, you extract the features, and
then you train your car
versus non-car classifier.
At testing time,
what you do is, you again,
you're going to take your new image, and
you're going to take this window and
you're going to slide it all over.
Until, hopefully, you end up, you land
over here and you classify it as a car.